peace talks with the Taliban are dead
President Trump saying he won't go
forward after canceling a secret summit
at Camp David with a terror group to end
the Afghanistan war Trump pulling the
plug after her Taliban leaders claimed
responsibility for an attack that killed
a US soldier and 11 others the Taliban
responding to the president's move by
threatening more Americans will die as a
result reaction is pouring in from both
sides of the political aisle watch it's
just another example of the president
treating foreign policy like it's some
kind of game show the Donald Trump is
not afraid to walk away from a bad video
this is the worst president when it
comes to negotiating it's more of his
erratic behavior that people are tired
of I think the president was right to
cancel the meeting I think what he's
trying to do is fulfill a campaign
promise for the u.s. to meet with the
Taliban and not have the leader of
Afghanistan - might meet with the
Taliban is something that's doomed to
failure
while speaking with reporters President
Trump calling off future talks with the
Taliban and it is defending trying to
hold them in the first place I'm
concerned they're dead they thought that
they had killed people in order to put
themselves in a little better
negotiating position you can't do that
can't do that with me so they're dead as
far as I'm concerned I like the idea of
meeting I've met with a lot of bad
people and a lot of good people during
the course of the last almost three
years and I think meeting is a great
thing I think that meeting with you know
you're talking about war there are
meetings with war otherwise wars would
never end you'd have them going forever
we had a meeting scheduled it was my
idea and it was my idea to terminate it
as he is the decider Brian the Taliban
was set up for an incredible propaganda
opportunity at Camp David and they blow
it so their arrogance might have done
them in but maybe that's good a couple
of things I mean the attacks were
happening in a pretty steady basis and
according to State Department we were
attacking them pretty much - and we
killed about a thousand people over the
last month they said of Taliban because
they were getting a little bit
belligerent but the way the president
wanted to have it the reports were he
was I wanted meet with the Taliban then
I wanted to meet with the sitting
government they wanted to go and have a
ceremony say hey look look what I did
here's the ceremony he's
the president said no I don't want a
celebration what I want to do is get
this thing across the goal line I want
to look these guys in the eye and see if
they're serious about taking the next
step it was his idea to choose Camp
David
it was Cal Assad's idea to bring him to
Washington it was
Pompeyo and Cal Assad who put together
the nine rounds of talks but ultimately
I think the president made the right
decision they're not ready to talk peace
they were high-fiving as if they early
they already were successful they were
saying we slayed another superpower that
was to talk in between sessions and
clearly they didn't right and Jesse
there were two narratives right so the
United States is trying to say we need
this out of a political necessity this
Wars gone on too long we need to figure
out a way to extricate ourselves in a
way that doesn't hurt our national
security and we think this is the way
forward and the Taliban was basically
saying we have run off the United States
of America and aren't we great and now
those two things were never going to be
able to remain without colliding at some
point I don't like the symbolism of the
Taliban coming to Camp David it's
hallowed ground for American diplomacy
and the American presidency these people
are barbaric they make Kim's jung-hoon
look refined let's remember Kim jong-un
barbarian - but he has his henchmen do
his dirty work for him
the Taliban personally stoned women they
personally commit atrocities they
personally do horrible horrible things
you can't even say here on television so
to give them that Camp David platform I
think was a bad idea and I'm glad the
president canceled it we have had bad
guys at Camp David before we've had
Soviet leaders we've had Yasser Arafat
but not to this level I understand the
president wanting to withdraw from
Afghanistan all powers eventually fight
there and then they leave we just want
to leave on our own terms and I believe
as generals and as strategists we're
trying to lock those terms in so they
could leave with some sense of
accomplishment but also not just leave
Afghanistan for terrorists to
reconstitute themselves and launch
attacks here so at the end of the day I
think it's going to be a long process
and we need to do something to end this
war and spend the tens of billions of
dollars that we're spending there have
it spent here well one of the things one
is that the Taliban had just recently
refused to acknowledge that al Qaeda was
responsible for 9/11
like within the last three weeks well
you know it's incredible we haven't said
it but I mean this week is the
anniversary mark we use Americans will
mark another I think it's now at 18
years since 9/11 and the idea that the
president would invite these people who
were the hosts for the terrorists who
attacked this al Qaeda to come to this
country I find incredible I don't think
that was Pompeo
I don't think that was crazy it was the
president's that's what I said it was
his idea no I think you're saying hey
wait there are other people here who are
putting things together I think he's the
guy who's the president he's the man who
the buck stops with him and he approved
of this idea which I find just includes
like what Obama wanted to try Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed here in Manhattan
there's a huge outrage against that I
also understand this was not the right
time I don't think I just think there's
a huge difference between saying we're
gonna put someone on trial for an
atrocity versus what we saw here which
is bring them in right have them at Camp
David give them added credibility
treatment right so I just think that was
crazy but I would say this I think polls
show the American people want this over
want us to get out I think Trump has the
right instinct there but when you stop
and think about the idea that you are
giving credibility to people who are
terrorists and they don't even have a
deal with the government in Kabul their
own government and we saw what happened
when the Soviets pulled out it just led
to chaos and more fractionalization and
more terrorists taking root there I
think we were going at it in the wrong
way one final point Dana how can we
invite these guys when we're saying to
the people who are fleeing the Bahamas
in the devastation oh you can't come in
here that's an outrage well I think
those are two very different things I
was begging about the investment and the
return on investment that we have
achieved over the last 18 years the
ability for women and children to be
freer to be able to go to school that
may not be afraid of their for their
lives even though that's not true across
the board and also to be able to prevent
al Qaeda from being able to attack us
from there that investment has paid off
somewhat right and president Trump is
cornered in the same way that even
President Obama was that if you pull out
of Afghanistan you expose potentially
the u.s. to another major terrorist
attack The Wall Street Journal editorial
page right
about this very thing hard as it may be
to accept the fight against Islamic
terrorism will be a multi-generational
struggle around the world better to stay
on offense on their turf than to retreat
to playing defense on America's far
better to have Muslim allies fighting by
our side in their countries than to play
pre-emptive and reprisal attacks from
the air and far away the Clinton years
showed us that pinprick missile attacks
alone do not stop al Qaeda but to the
Jessi's point about Camp David people
hear Taliban at Camp David those
forwards and I know a lot of Americans
probably went oh hell no and the point
is it's not happening it's not happening
Isis also in Afghanistan that we know of
and the Haqqani network we can't leave
yet understand all the presidents to do
is say I'm gonna draw down but I can't
pull out because I saw what happened in
Iraq and if you read general mattis's
book he said I didn't want to make this
a political book I finished it in 2017
then I get asked to become Secretary of
Defense what he said they told they told
Vice President Biden and his dignitaries
if you pull out there's no Qaeda group
ready to move in and they pulled out
anyway right so if the president pulls
out he's not saying I want to dominate a
country it's not saying I want to teach
them democracy
the president says I'm gonna keep 8,500
or 10,000 in there to give us an idea
what's happening on the ground with Isis
al Qaeda and all the terrorist
activities that are going across the
Pakistani Afghan border if you want to
talk about how to better spend the money
that we're writing to the government
absolutely if you want to get more
allies involved absolutely where the
president just explained this isn't
about standing up Afghanistan it's about
an out it's about a spyglass into the
terror networks that are existing and
thriving there and we get countless
benefits unending benefits from being
there and understanding yeah that's an
important point is that you're leaving a
counter and terror group in there to
launch operations and then also gain
intelligence but also maybe leave some
smart people that it can enterprise some
of the vast mineral wealth in
Afghanistan so maybe we could get paid
back for all of the work that we've been
well you know it's been 18 years 18
years we've been there and how many
weeks that we have you're wanting on 18
years three presidents I think we've got
2,300 Americans dead 3,500 if you
include the ally forces so I think it's
time
for us to think about is how we handle
this because we're not there just last
year know that these are two different
things but we've had troops in Europe
since the end of World War two and we've
had troops in Korea since the Armistice
in 1953 those are two different stories
generational struggle but again we don't
call those forever wars